wo ist dein weg
2 und mädchen
wir kennen uns doch oder frau kohler
engel wie geht's dir liebe es nicht sehr
gut mein vater hatte einen zusammenbruch
und das ist ja schrecklich ich hoffe
dass es ihm bald wieder gut geht
ich hoffe er hat zu viel stress er muss
sich jetzt ausruhen und wie geht es
ihnen blendend
ich war gerade beim arzt kleinigkeiten
ich finde dass ich fit wie ein turnschuh
bin und was macht man so was macht der
sondern er sucht nach altenheimen er
denkt dass das gut für mich ist er
machte als trainer glaubt dass ich
einsam bin also ein quatsch ich bin noch
nicht einsam
er meint es bestimmt gut frau eine
entschuldigung natürlich du willst du
deinem vater mir geht es gut kein
problem also los danke